[Music]
on this Saturday night an Ottawa teen
facing Terror charges his father speaks
to Global News he never Ed violence
nothing you know the alleged plot the
Target and the possible
motive sorrow and
anger the devastating details behind the
mistaken killing of three Israeli
hostages by the
IDF fake art finds BC's bogus Group of
Seven exhibit
Canada's longest running radio
documentary show celebrates a milestone
the ongoing history of new music is a
throwback to the old days when you would
turn on the radio why what's old is
attracting new
audiences global national with barin
Asser good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin with breaking news
tonight a global news exclusive out of
Ottawa where a high school student has
been arrested by the RCMP in relation to
an alleged terrorism plot against the
Jewish Community let's get right to our
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa Mercedes how did this all unfold
far last night the RCMP carried out a
highly sensitive National Security
operation here in Ottawa arresting a
teenager on terror charges a story that
we broke earlier this afternoon the
investigation involved multiple police
forces and cus Canada's spy agency the
RCMP say the target was the Jewish
Community the teenager is charged with
facilitation of terrorist activity by
communicating instructional material
related to an explosive substance and
he's also charged with knowingly
instructing directly or indirectly a
person to carry out a terrorist attack
against Jewish persons sources say RCMP
Tactical Team was on hand for the arrest
as were officers from the chemical
biological nuclear and high explosives
team not a surprise given what those
charges had to say about communicating
instructions on an explosive substance
for terrorist activity two national
security sources say the teen was
ideologically motivated and that he was
influenced by someone they believe who
was involved with a group that has an
ideology that is Isis like the young
man's father spoke with global news
outside the courthouse earlier today
after his son appeared he said the boy
is in grade 10 and that he's been
concerned about religious extremists
trying to radicalize his son and I him
many time he me and his mother uh stay
away from you know extremist or
something you know we never had this in
in the family uh we don't have but it
seems um you know I think he's you know
he's M he's 15 years old I think they
try to use him and they stay in some
people that's what I think some ex they
try to use him he's he's kind of naive
he never use violence nothing you know
he um I mean I'm
surprised the boy's father told us that
he and the mother of the teenager had
tried to set up counseling with an imom
at a local mosque but it's unclear
whether the teen followed through
National Security sources have told me
that they are deeply concerned about
threats to the Jewish community in
Canada from both Neo-Nazi hate groups
and groups like Isis there are active
investigations unfolding across the
country tonight sources in the Jewish
Community say they are afraid but also
relieved that police are acting the
Canadian Center for Israel Jewish
Affairs told Global News the arrest and
charges laid today against an individual
are a staggering development of what
unchecked anti-Semitism has become in
our
country and Mercedes you've also heard
from your National Security sources that
this is not a one-off case uh and it
isn't limited to one group specifically
being
targeted that's corrected in fact in a
press release tonight it matched what my
source ources had been telling me that
the RCMP put out saying that there have
been five youth this year that means
people under the age of 18 who have been
charged with terrorism charges that's a
really serious charge and they're
looking at a number of different groups
there's concern about neo-nazis like
Adam wafin division targeting youth
there's concerns about Isis targeting
youth but the commonality is this
attempt to influence young people and
the RCMP are actually so concerned that
they are launching a national campaign
to educate parents of the signs of
radical radicalization and we have two
examples up on the screen there you can
see of the kind of material that police
have used in the past and that I'm told
they are planning to use again and we
just have a couple of things quickly far
that police are asking parents to watch
for tonight including if your child
appears to be increasingly exclusive in
their association with social groups
promoting violence expression of Us
Versus Them mentalities the
dehumanization of others and extreme
anti-government attitudes they're saying
if you see any of that you should get
involved okay Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thanks for your coverage on this
and you can read more about the alleged
Terror plot Mercedes spoke about on our
website globalnews.ca
to the Middle East now Fallout after
Friday's news that the Israeli military
mistakenly killed three Hamas hostages
in Gaza the tragedy has realized the
fears of family members whose loved ones
were taken captive by Hamas on October
7th now most of their loved ones have
long worried The Siege is endangering
the hostages further despite Israel's
error it continues its bombardment in
Gaza in a war which has already killed
thousands of Palestinians many of them
women and children but as Sha oay
reports this incident is fueling
stronger calls from within Israel to
stop hostilities
altogether the bombardment of Gaza
didn't let up on Saturday even in the
wake of a deadly mistake on Friday three
Israeli hostages held captive since
October 7th were shot and killed killed
a terrible blunder which the Israeli
Defense Forces acknowledged admitting
their soldiers mistakenly identified
three kidnapped Israelis as a threat
published reports in Israel say a
military investigation has found the men
were barechested and carrying a white
flag when they were shot all three men
were in their 20s they had somehow
escaped their captors when they were
approaching a military position in Gaza
City in Israel the news was another blow
for the families of hostages who live in
Hope and fear here my reaction first of
all was grief these are families that I
know personally and people that have
been waiting so hopefully for their
loved ones to
return hundreds of protesters blocked a
main Highway in Tel Aviv calling for the
hostages
return while more than a 100 hostages
have been released a similar number are
still missing many families want
negotiations not more fighting to get
their loved ones back and put the best
offer on the table to get the hostages
back
alive
alive we don't want them back in bags
there is a need to just stop and and
talk the head of the Palestinian
delegation to Canada says it's time for
Israel to stop its military action in
Gaza the way Israel is portraying um its
war on Hamas uh is not really a war on
Hamas it's a war on the Palestinian
People Israel says it's targeting Hamas
not civilians insisting the group's
Fighters intentionally use civilians as
cover this week Canada joined Australia
and New Zealand at the United Nations
voting for what it called an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire but that
ceasefire can't be
one-sided Hamas needs to lay down its
arms Hamas needs to free all the
hostages they have right now The
Accidental deaths of the hostages at the
hands of the military has family members
watching the clock more closely we have
no time that's what my clock that I took
to the United States an meeting says we
have no time sh sh Global News
Toronto in the Red Sea us and UK naval
ships have engaged over a dozen attack
drones marking the latest hostilities on
ships traveling in that region Britain's
defense secretary says the British
vessel shot down a suspected attack
drone targeting a merchant ship and US
officials say an American Destroyer took
down 14 others iran-backed houthi Rebels
from Yemen have recently attacked ships
they suspect are linked to Israel due to
the crisis in Gaza and it's caused some
major transportation companies to pause
operations in the Red
Sea Winnipeg police are investigating
the stabbing death of a teenage girl
yesterday afternoon it happened in broad
daylight in a busy part of downtown
investigators say she was rushed to
hospital and she underwent emergency
surgery but sadly died from her injuries
no arrests have been made police are
looking for multiple suspects who left
the scene and they will provide more
information to the public on
Monday a salmonella outbreak across this
country has now claimed six lives with a
number of confirmed cases continuing to
rise since October 153 people across
Canada have been diagnosed with
salmonella linked to the outbreak the
cases are now spread out across eight
provinces with Quebec having the most
most amount of cases at 103 on Friday
Mexico's Health Department ordered the
temporary closure of a melon packing
plant implicated in the infections now
they did not name the company involved
but Canada's public health agency has
linked the outbreak to Malita and Ruby
brand cantelopes
opposition MPS are demanding Ottawa
block beijing's acquisition of Canada's
only Rare Earth mining company that says
China acquires shares in the Australian
firm that owns it in a statement the
conservatives say Ottawa has the
responsibility to trigger a National
Security review of this investment as
hadidi pachic reports industry insiders
want Ottawa to take more assertive
action to keep China out of domestic
resources they help power the modern
world Rare Earth elements used to make
permanent magnets for smartphones
electric vehicles wind turbines but a
year after the federal government
announced its plan to spend billions on
boosting a locally sourced Supply there
are concerns Ottawa isn't doing enough
to protect that Supply from China the
dominant player in the global market
this is a non-existent supply chain
actually in Canada Halifax based ukor
plans to use proprietary technology to
process Rare Earth elements at a plant
in Ontario and it hopes to eventually
purchase raw material from Canada's
first operating Rare Earth mine the
nechalacho mine in the Northwest
Territories but an initial Financial
investment in the struggling Australian
company behind that mine vital medals by
a major Chinese player shangu resources
has triggered concerns it could mean
eventual diversion of the mineral
resources to China neither company
returned requests for comment from
Global News we've seen them do that in
Africa and we know that most likely this
will be the same result in Canada too it
happened with a Canadian lithium mine in
2021 leading Ottawa to announce tighter
rules for critical mineral Investments
as soon as those uh Acquisitions are
proposed by entities headquartered in
China they should be an automatic review
by this Minister and the minister should
stop them from happening the federal
department responsible would only tell
Global News its quote aware of the
proposed transaction and writes in a
statement in part the confidentiality
provisions of the investment Canada act
mean the government cannot comment on
reviews how is it that we are still
relying on a Chinese investor to come
with again6 million 9 million $15
million to save a Canadian rare Earths
project um from facing demise without
enough domestic investment she says
fledgling Rare Earth companies have few
financing options to get product out of
the ground and meet ottawa's goal of
sourcing Canadian supply for growing
Global demand Heidi pic Global News
Halifax a Roman Catholic Cardinal has
been convicted of embezzlement by a
Vatican Tribunal C Angelo betu is the
first Cardinal ever prosecuted by the
Vatican Criminal Court he was sentenced
to 5 and a half years in jail the
charges are related to a money losing
investment at a London property the 2
and a half year trial dubbed the
vatican's trial of the century involved
10 defendants and almost 50 charges
brought against
them featured forgeries in Vancouver's
Art Gallery coming up why these
counterfeits of Canadian Masterworks are
getting the spotlight plus the conflict
iting views over a possible ceasefire in
Gaza between Canada and its closest Ally
at the United Nations the US ambassador
to Canada weighs
[Music]
in Canada's renowned Group of Seven are
best known for their paintings inspired
by Canadian Landscapes their world
famous art movement dates back to the
early
1900s now forgeries of some of those
works are the focus of a unique exhibit
in Vancouver and as Katherine urkhart
reports it's not the only fraudulent art
making headlines this week initially the
10 oil sketches were thought to be works
by Canadian artist je McDonald who
founded the influential Group of Seven
in the 1920s and 30s all turned out to
be fakes but you're also given an
opportunity here to test your own ey now
they're part of a CSI type Exhibition at
the Vancouver art gallery and it tells
the story of the Vancouver AR gallery's
investigation uh of these sketches in
all its forms uh it does this as you'll
see with uh video interviews with many
of the key participants with documents
from the research that's been undertaken
and of course with uh artworks from our
collection the purported Masterworks
were acquired in 2015 questions about
their authenticity soon followed an
in-depth investigation revealed it was
impossible they could be legitimate
the sketches each contained one or more
pigments that weren't available during
McDonald's lifetime showing that he
couldn't have painted these Works across
the country in thunderbay Ontario a man
accused of counterfeiting hundreds of
works by indigenous artist norval
morriso was handed a 5-year prison term
this week it was the largest art fraud
in Canadian history three of the works
on this wall are contested works and the
rest are all securely attributed in
Vancouver the 5 months long exhibit of
fake McDonald's is meant to educate and
provoke thought it's a great opportunity
to have a public conversation about the
importance of art about visual
information about the media this
Vancouver Art Gallery display surely one
of its more unique exhibitions Katherine
art Global News Vancouver
[Music]
ahead Washington and Ottawa at odds at
the UN a US top Diplomat reacts to
Canada's call for a
[Music]
ceasefire earlier this week Canada voted
in favor of the United Nations
resolution calling for an immediate
ceasefire in the Israel Hamas War but
the US was one of 10 countries to vote
against the non-binding resolution
meaning the two countries are no longer
on the same page publicly when it comes
to the war mer Stevenson joins us once
again from Ottawa with a reaction from
the US ambassador to Canada
Mercedes Farah it was a significant
shift in Canada's positioning this week
with Canada calling for a ceasefire in
the Israel Hamas War I asked us
Ambassador David Cohen if he was
surprised by ottawa's position when it
diverged from Washington Cohen said that
while he was not given a heads up
warning him that Canada was going to
change their tone he wasn't shocked
either having noticed a building
momentum and domestic pressure in Canada
to adopt the position of a ceasefire
look I was not surprised by it I sort of
see the tea leaves as you do and anyone
who was paying attention I also asked
Cohen about National Security threats
including Iranian regime officials who
are operating here in Canada and calls
from American lawmakers to designate the
Iranian revolutionary guard Corps a
terrorist group in Canada I asked the
Ambassador if that is what the Biden
Administration is looking for we'll find
out on the show and we'll take a look at
the state of Canada's military
Ambassador Cohen takes a harder line on
Canada needing to address threats I'm to
focused on Continental defense and
making sure that Canada and the United
States together under the opes of NORAD
are in a position to defend our homeland
and no secret that I don't think the
level of spending now was sufficient to
be able to accomplish that objective
Ambassador Cohen was optimistic with me
about the Liberals upcoming long awaited
defense policy review but with a
presidential election coming there's
lots of big questions that will be up in
the air about the Canada US relationship
far Mercedes thanks again you can watch
Mercedes full interview with US
ambassador to Canada David Cohen on
tomorrow's the West block right here on
global history goes on next celebrating
a milestone for a Canadian music
[Music]
historian there are not many people on
the planet who have a Rolodex of rock
stars they can call anytime for an
interview but you see Alan Cross is not
like most people the music historian
author and syndicated chorus radio host
just celebrated a milestone of his
trailblazing show the ongoing history of
new music I spoke with Alan about some
of his Unforgettable moments along the
way Sunday night if professional music
geek was a job it would belong to Alan
Cross I'm still here in 2023 doing a
show that began in 1993 cross's
groundbreaking syndicated radio show the
ongoing history of new music just
celebrated its 1,000th episode and in
that time he's experienced a life most
Canadians could only dream of partying
with Bono having drinks with Springsteen
and flying to London for a middle of the
night interview with the cures Robert
Smith Robert does his work day from 8:00
p.m. to 5:00 a.m. it was me and him
oneon-one in a dark hotel room at
between 2: and 3:30 in the morning
talking about him and his band cross
sees himself as a proxy for every music
fan that can't be in those rooms but
it's not just his access or encyclopedic
knowledge that connects him to fans it's
his storytelling like the story of about
how he was about to lose his job when
the rock station in Toronto he was
working for was about to change to a
country music station but the new
management looked around and saw that
there were these bands like Nirvana and
Pearl Jam and sound gard and Alice and
change and the Red Hot Chili Peppers and
so on thought no this seems to be a a
growing thing here in the early 1990s so
we're going to maintain this alternative
rock format but what we're also going to
do is make it a lot more accessible to
all these new listeners that we think
that we're going to have and in order to
do that we are going to have to have a
program that explains what where all
this music came from and what it's all
about put everything into context so
they looked around the staff they found
one person with a history degree me and
they said you were doing this job soon
after a major tragedy in the music world
would take place I was on the air when
Kurt Coan died I remember thinking that
you know don't screw this up because we
are dealing with real time information
in a pre-internet era people forget that
radio used to be the social media of the
time in the age of music streaming cross
has enjoyed even more success his show
the longest running music documentary
program in Canada has seen 21 million
podcast downloads spanning almost every
country in the world back in the old
days we would have music magazines and
we would have the person on the radio we
would have the guy at the record store
and then we would have the physical
piece of music itself the album artwork
the liner notes the lyrics all those
things and we don't have that anymore in
a sense the ongoing history of new music
is a throwback to the old days when you
would turn on the radio and the person
on the other side of the speakers would
tell you why the song the album The
Artist the scene the sound why all these
things mattered context from the olden
days is gaining cross a new audience the
kids of his original fans that now tune
in for his take in an evolving
industry congratulations Allen from all
of your friends at Global News and that
is global national for this Saturday
night I'm far Naser and on behalf of our
whole crew here I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your Saturday
evening with us and tonight's here
Canada is Vancouver's Filipino Christmas
Market it's an annual tradition with
more than 40 vendors of festive food and
gifts we love seeing your Canada please
email us your photos to viewers at
Global
national.com until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
night